Happy Kong Pee-Pee, everybody.
Welcome to Densetsu versus Beasties.
Papa Quiz!
What is Papa Quiz?
I don't know.
We actually don't know.
Not a clue.
It's an amazing game.
Incredible.
You guys are gonna love it.
I'm excited.
Yeah.
This is a big game.
It's really...
does have a advantage in this game being that it is Vicky's
favorite game.
I mean, we have a person advantage.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, I literally haven't played it like a year,
but okay.
Do we have a person?
Ferry, I don't know what side you're on.
Wait, wait, that's not an advantage.
Trader action.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I can do it.
I can do it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, what about this?
I'm sitting.
You look so polite.
She hit the floor.
Shorty got low.
How is it?
Do you like it?
Is it nice?
The metal chair?
I would like to be on the team that I was supposed to, you
know, I'd like to be on a specific side.
And who's that?
Yeah, who's that?
Okay, wait, let's do a self-introduction.
Wait, hold on, hold on, guys.
Ladies, ladies.
That's not me.
Speaking of, speaking of sides, why don't we start with
introductions from the Densetsu EXE side?
BROAM!
Okay!
Uh, in order, oh, which, I don't know what order we're in.
Okay, in this order.
We can go in order, yeah.
Okay!
Vicky, Phoebe, Mint.
Hello, everyone!
I'm Victoria Roman!
Uh, yeah!
Inca, in-ca and retro stuff is my jam.
and I'm part of Densets.exe.
Thank you!
Yay!
Woohoo!
Who's next?
And...
Ball fairy.
Oh, very, okay.
Uh, Ohachi!
I'm Phoebe, your 2.5D blooming flower idol.
Love to write music and perform it on both the real life and
the virtual stage.
And, and I like Utschi's balls.
Ooh!
Yeah, I'm part of Denchetsu.exe.
Thanks for having me.
Yummy!
Woo!
Sorry.
You can do it.
Guys, she's new here.
She's nervous.
No pressure, no pressure.
Can someone whisper the lines into my ear?
Oh, my boo.
Yeah, yeah.
My, my boo!
Six, seven.
6-7 Chris early
I'm the lone member of the Density Yixie who is anti 6-7
It's nice to meet you Yeah!
We'll convert her one day, chat.
We'll convert her one day.
And now for the fourth member of Densatsu.
Steiner!
Steiner, I know you're in here!
Yeah!
Oh, okay.
Well, nobody's cheering for Steiner.
Oh, that one.
Wait.
it's so quiet what the hell we're waiting we're waiting
we're waiting uh okay uh hi everyone my name is barry and i
am a bug hello hello hi yay i am formerly of densetsu for in
in parentheses one day one day and then but i'm a beasties
member yippee yay yay yay MVP be forever.
Stop spamming the chair emoji.
See you guys.
It's her new Oshimark.
It's beautiful.
Oh!
Ladybug chair.
Make it official.
It just makes sense.
Next up is the Cotton Candy Queen.
Oh, I don't know about that, but Torio.
My name is Torio Oriana.
I'm a soul fairy man.
Member of Beasties, might I add?
Oh my god.
Thank you.
No, well, please.
Okay, you're too kind.
Oh my god.
It's over, man.
No, we're not fighting.
We're already inviting.
I'm just, you know, if Barry wants to fly away off into the
sunset, that's okay.
Ooh, I'm sensing some tension within Beasties.
No.
Everything's going great.
It's going to affect their pop lying and their crazy.
Everything's going awesome.
Everything is awesome.
Everything is fine.
Hi.
And you're part of a team.
Especially when-
Once we bring this home, I think that'll solidify us as a
unit again.
Isn't that right?
Is that right?
Hmm.
Home cheater.
Welcome home cheater.
No, no, no, no.
Guys, I am so...
Can I just say...
Steiner DM'd me and he said I should throw for...
If I throw for the... for Beastie, and I let Densetsu win,
he'll make me Gen 2.
What?
Bro, Steiner, that's scandalous!
Steiner!
She's getting scared, dude!
Listen, I would never betray...
I would never betray my Nakama like that, dude, you know?
The Nakama.
My Nakama, as Luffy would say.
Luffy would never.
You'll be seen.
next up is croc kyle crocodile i'm not you always say kyle
my name is kyle crocodile i'm a crocodile and i'm also part
of the bc's always been part of the bc's for the record okay
wait hold on me me too me too me too you're really selling
it barry
Oh, and then un- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, the- Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, happy cone PP, uh, Gremlin slime with the heart of
gold, PAP UFO, uh, Slimiest member of the Beasties at your
service.
Mm-hmm.
Woo, woo, woo.
Woo.
Woo!
I love my genmates so much.
Crock and Tori, uh, and there was a fourth one.
We don't talk about her.
her anymore.
No, uh, uh, well, anyway, I'm sure I'll remember soon
enough.
Oh my god, it's over, man.
I'm leaving because of that.
We don't talk about berries.
No, no, no.
I'm like in the steel chair.
It's like Voldemort.
We don't bring it up.
Bugs on your back.
But yes, today is the battle of the brain smarts versus the
brain farts in Papa Quiz, where we determine which team has
got the most brain cells of all of us.
Mm-hmm.
Although I heard that this game is more of a fast finger
affair than it is like an actual difficult battle of wits.
Yeah.
Oh no.
I don't think I know what that means.
Also, the fast finger there has the advantage.
All you have to do is fast I'm gonna need a little bit help.
Going right.
Oh, your fast finger.
What?
Who is who?
Wait, can we introduce ourselves again?
Oh yeah, you're so right.
We introduce ourselves.
Speed run.
Why did it turn to arrows?
I see it too.
Lady nut.
You would be.
That's what would be.
Yay!
Someone kick Lady nut.
Kick Lady nut.
No, hey!
I'm Mr. Beer.
Mr. Beard!
I'm flash flashy.
There's a joke here about flashing if things go south for
the quiz.
Give me a little bit, I'll cook it up.
Okay, well, I'm big love, otherwise known as the streets
call me BL.
that's so good we love bl here yeah yeah our streets love bl
man
uh by the way pia if there's any way you can turn up your
microphone i turned you up on discord side but doesn't seem
to have done much but i already turned you up 150 so maybe
not too much how about that yeah hopefully that's good a
little bit more oh wait next is me um fat finger i love the
tea the cup of tea on your head oh isn't it a nice touch i
thought it would be lovely the british one
wait yeah you would be the whole
I don't go in here.
Tiny flower.
Definitely not a little baby.
Yeah, that was fitting.
So cute.
I'm cosplaying my rat.
Yeah, I'm cosplaying Suki.
Oh, cute!
Aww.
I feel like I remember Suki being a bit cute than that, to
be honest.
But...
The eyes are a little...
Yeah, I must say we are all looking kind of rough.
Maybe.
Speak for yourself, B.A.
Okay, all right, hold on.
First question is beautiful.
Just all love and peace.
Big love wants love and peace.
Big love stands for love, man.
I think you threw out love when you betrayed your team.
That's what I'm saying.
Man.
Maybe I gotta start this game before we kill each other.
We can do it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Mr. Montgomery.
Show me the players.
Oh, we have a bingo board.
There we are.
We spread it.
We have a bingo board.
Miss your beard.
Flash flashy.
Yeah.
Go back to the lab.
Yeah, do the worm.
Fat finger.
Yeah.
Tiny flower
We need to choose a category.
Oh god.
All right.
It's phone time Everybody tap tap tap on your buttons Game
of Thrones.
Oh god.
I got all your names.
Oh Food!
Food, I guess!
It's older, man.
It's actual.
Did we even click that?
We just...
Guys, you have to keep clicking for the one you want.
Let's start with the first one.
I can't even see my mouse.
Really?
The more points you get.
But remember that you have to answer correctly too.
Okay.
Come on, kids.
We're on food, right?
Food?
We're just writing food?
Where were tacos invented?
Oh my god.
Oh, I wonder...
if I'm right, but...
Did I even...
Is it just an arrow's butt?
Oh, it's how fast you are.
Which animal is on the fruit loops?
Serial box.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, I got that so good.
I got it.
No, bro.
I keep tapping you.
I don't...
I got it!
I got it.
I'm locked in there.
I lift up the TV.
The big love gets so close to the screen, you can't even see
it.
Oh, fuck, I misclicked.
I misclicked.
I know it's in the eye then.
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I didn't get it?
Oh, wait, I'm blaming the ping.
I was so fast.
The ping, the ping in Asia.
A fruit?
I can't read this fast.
How are you guys reading this fast?
AIM labs before this is collect.
Yeah, we're ready, man.
It's the pink.
I was training.
I know this one!
Baby, if you didn't get this first, this is a...
I have butter!
You have butter!
I think I hit syrup.
Phoebe is throwing.
Flash, flashy.
I need to splashy with a crotch out.
Oh my gosh.
I got you with the sassy thoughts.
Oh yeah.
Oh.
Flash, are you doing what she does best?
Oh yeah.
That's my girl.
Shake it.
It's time to choose a new category.
Okay, Papa.
So silly.
Tap, tap, tap to choose a category.
Okay, Papa.
Tap tap tap guys Tap tap Okay Don't let her Don't let her
Don't let her Let's go Dude she's got like an auto clicker
or something She auto clicked England Please auto clicker it
over We're so cool What the picture is What?
Okay?
Oh shoot Okay Excellent.
Is this photo taken?
Oh god.
Big Ben.
Oh, I have no idea.
What is that?
I know it.
I'm guessing.
I don't know.
What is that?
I'm guessing.
I got it.
What?
I guess?
I don't want a clue.
I really hope I'm right.
Fuck, I didn't get it.
All right.
Well, it's over.
Guys, don't worry.
I got it.
Big love.
attraction.
Oh god.
It's Big Ben.
Oh, it's the two.
The London Eye.
Oh my god.
Wait, the wheel?
Is it wheel or eye?
No, it's the London Eye.
It's the eye.
Oh god, I'm close.
I panicked.
I didn't meet the Brits as much as I can.
This is awful.
Wait, wait.
I panicked.
Wait, where did we go?
We're back.
Wait, I missed a question.
It's Cambridge.
I just know it.
I don't know.
I'm trying to be around my soul.
Brightness fancy.
Yes, we're good.
That's over there.
I thought that was so good.
Yeah, baby!
I was right!
I knew it was College of London!
Flashy, my god, you're goaded!
London!
London Bridge!
I already chose London Bridge, I just hope.
I pray.
Is that London?
No, it's Tower Bridge!
It's Tower Bridge!
All the bridges look the same.
I'm bringing it back.
What is it?
Hello?
What does that mean?
First off.
It's in Tynemouth actually.
Who knows?
It's in Tynemouth.
I have a 25% chance to get it frame one.
Tynemouth.
Oh, that was gone first.
Yes!
Oh, my gosh.
You are not real.
Can we talk about how big Vicky and Pia go with the most
British person?
Oh my gosh.
Pia.
Do a British accent.
We could do a really British dance.
Yeah.
The banana bounce.
Oh, that's so cute.
Don't even bounce on it.
Wow, so you risk...
I showed it a yellow submarine.
A yellow submarine.
Witness Lady Nut, everyone.
Okay, okay.
OK.
OK, doki.
A new category.
OK, doki, doki.
OK, doki.
Monte, they know the drill.
Tap, tap, tap.
Tap, tap.
Okay.
Pokémon!
Rock, walk in!
You better get everything!
It called this the junior?
It called the junior category?
What the hell?
So much fun.
Point fincher.
Oh, I know!
Points!
Okay, okay.
Scary.
Pokémon.
Okay, we got...
to pokeball okay oh i think i got it was i fast enough woo
oh okay oh so fast was i fast enough and oh still oh big
love choose not me no please no please wow wow Maybe you
wish it's something true.
This is how I meant to steal from her.
Sabotage.
Her true colors come forward.
I meant to steal from her.
What?
Big love, this is your chance again.
Not me, not me, not me, not me, no me, no me.
What the hell?
Wait, you guys, I'm waiting.
I'm trying to get back to her.
I'm trying to steal from Vicky.
Very.
I wasn't even paying attention.
I was so betrayed.
It took me three seconds.
Let's go!
The timing is...
Wait, okay, Tori, look at the timing.
No, not me, not me, not me.
Who's who?
Bad finger.
I'm the last three, the last three.
The beasties are all the very first four.
I'm Mr. Binn.
Oh no!
You're insane, you're insane, you're insane.
The timing is weird.
Beasties hating you.
I'm just looking at the screen.
Don't be sad.
Don't be sad, Lady Nod.
Lady Love, go ahead and do your dance victory.
Yii!
Yo, Gangnam Style!
It's like, oh my god, Gangnam Style!
Oh my god, Gangnam Style!
That's so nice that they let Lady Love do a pity dance.
So nice.
Wow.
Monty Gov. The new category.
Touch the buttons to move the arrows.
Monty, stop it.
Yes, stop it, Monty.
Stop it.
I don't think I didn't notice how you didn't get first for
any of those Pokemon.
questions oh dang sure you sure we never seem to like we all
seem to all agree on the category yeah yeah we are too
predictable round okay what is this uh i know this one oh
what is this like like showing a cat breed maybe don't click
don't click impulsively wait okay okay which cat I don't
know.
All of them, probably.
I know, right?
Well, it showed one wild one, and then one, and then the
mist are just cowscats.
Oh, I keep accidentally picking the wrong freaking...
Oh, my God.
I didn't know.
I thought we were...
Why were we...
Do we just click when it shows it on the screen?
If it shows up, you can.
I mean, the links are the dangers.
But, like, usually it doesn't show up first picture.
Okay, I was expecting the others set up.
what is homeward bound that's a deep cut oh no bro i don't
know i don't know i missed clicked i messed up maybe my ping
my ping that one looks like a movie i might have missed
clicks ah whatever i knew that one i knew that one anybody
get it i've never even heard of this movie no fans of home
would bound me clearly okay oh fuck i misclicked oh my
fucking my fucking linear keyboard i should have been fat
fingers i should have been i'm taking the title from you
vicky i am not that oh oh oh stupid oh i did anything huge
bc's win oh no i didn't like you mint is that you wait i
think i don't know cats oh i didn't choose the category none
of these look british enough nobody has teeth i think i need
cats has to be that one I feel like a lot of cats, a lot of
cat people don't pay attention to like, uh, breed.
That's like a dog or something.
Oh, yeah.
It's cat.
Most cat owners are like, yeah, I found this cat in a
dumpster.
I feel like I have the correct answer in like 20 questions.
No, it's okay.
You're, you're the heart of the joke.
Oh, who's that?
Joe exotic.
Wait, it's, my goat.
My goat.
The tiger king.
Yeah, he's a tiger king.
Tigray king game.
Isn't he like crazy?
He's in jail right now.
Oh dang, I'm the only one who got it.
Oh dang.
Big love.
You got the most points.
Alright, watch this you guys.
This one's for my homie.
Oh yeah.
Stay the name of you.
Stay the name.
Zombie.
I'm doing the howling hips.
Howling hips.
The hamster group.
Damn.
Look at you.
I don't think we can show.
That's wow.
Those hamsters don't lie.
It's time for the last round.
Why are they gonging style?
Yeah, they're gonging.
The more points you score, the more time you get.
Oh, no.
Oh, shoot.
Last player remaining is the winner.
Okay.
Oh, no.
No, Phoebe.
Phoebe.
Phoebe, since you're purposely throwing, do you want to be
part of BC's Gen 2?
No, wait a minute, wait a minute, hold on, hold on.
We're mixed in and matching like crazy.
Westerns.
Westerns?
You guys can have Husky and me every other weekend.
What is that?
I'm just going to say something.
I don't know any of these words.
I don't know.
I know the name of this person.
Alright.
Oh, don't know.
Big loop.
No idea.
Big loop, Carrie.
This one's for my group, guys.
This one's for my group.
Say the name of the group.
Which rock, featured in Minecraft, is often formed when lava
cools quickly.
I know, I know.
Easy.
I got this one.
Holy lady, now you've got it like under a frame.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm finally...
Oh, guys, don't look.
Oh, no.
Minecraft!
I love Minecraft!
I need to play more Minecraft, clearly.
Famous catchphrases.
Hot dog.
When the Looney Tunes character famously asked Oh, easy.
Oh, shoot.
I low key...
Okay.
Tori's really sweating.
No, no, no, no.
Like, I knew it.
Like, I didn't know it until I saw the name.
You know what I mean?
I'll save us!
That's it too!
You can do it!
Oh, I'm hooked on geography.
Wait, geography.
I don't know.
Um, I guess.
Uh, wait.
Oh, actually, is it zero point zero?
Yes!
Zero seconds on her.
What the hell?
She's zero?
Whoa, Phoebe.
What the hell?
I don't want to be a part of Beasties Gen 2.
Australian TV.
Huh?
What neighbor's character is played by Natalie?
Oh, no.
I have no idea.
It's Beth Brennan, guys.
You keep getting zero seconds on this.
clock who sounds the most australian who's a center power
was marked by the long march of
it's winston churchill i don't know okay then i put winston
churchill
Oh, well, are you sent to believe you last time?
It's over.
That's right, Melvin.
Lady not walking.
I'm in trouble.
Kia, you're dead.
What is the name of the world's first clone sheet?
Oh, this is not 90s.
What?
I know it's wrong.
I think I got it wrong.
I think I know it.
Yeah, this one's a...
Oh, no, no, no!
No!
They feared the beasties win that was about to come.
They feared...
We're back, we're back, we're back, we're back, we're so
back, we're so back, we're so back, we're so back, we're so
back, we're so back, we're so back,
it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's They fell in their holes.
Franco-Belgian comics.
What the hell?
What is that?
What's the name of Obelix dog?
Dogmatix.
Come on.
It's actually dogmatix.
You guys need to catch up on your comics.
Dogmatix.
Which of the following is an anagram of Homer Simpson.
Oh, I know something.
Pomeranian, son.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I didn't know that.
That's interesting.
That's actually cool.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
It was cool.
Oh, Mr. Beard.
I thought it was, it was cool for a second.
It's no longer cool.
It's over.
No.
Beasties are here.
Welcome.
Disney.
For my group.
I always believed in my group.
Who's Tommy?
Oh I know I don't know.
I know.
It's gummy.
What gummy bears.
I got that.
I got me bears No, I play by myself now.
Yeah, Mr. Beard.
Mr. Beard, Mr. Beard, Mr. Beard.
Victory dance.
Mr. Beard's victory dance.
Oh, yes, Mr. Beard.
Can I be in a video?
Please, please, please.
This is how Mr. Beer dances.
Bring it now, Mr. Beer.
Oh yeah.
That's Michael Jackson.
Wow, that was fun.
Everybody get up and celebrate with some funky moves.
Yeah, funky moves!
Oh yeah!
Sorry, I was just clicking buttons.
No funky moves.
It's serious game time.
Back into the game.
one point we got one great is that wait wait so it just
matters until the end there i guess so i think that's how
unless we unless from this round on we take all of the point
totals i guess all the points are for the timer at the end
yeah yeah okay so you just gotta survive to the end to get
your team a point i think that's probably the fairest way
right i think so yeah yeah i'm I'm doing this for my team.
So was that a trial round or did that round count?
Yeah, you know that's that we were learning how to play.
Yeah, that was a warm up.
Yeah, warm up.
That was a warm up round from now on.
Yeah, and Vicky hadn't played in like a year so she didn't
remember how to play.
Yeah.
We didn't even know how to tap tap.
Even though we had a British, a British category.
I'm like fake British.
I can't believe I am the most British person in this game.
collab that's crazy it's so crazy pierre yeah yeah i think
you have to turn up i think you have to turn up vicky
somebody said vicky needs to be turned up too yeah it's a
good time let me adjust to me adjust audio is anybody else
on my end quiet yeah let me know on my end too i think i I
think Pia was adjusted, so I think it should be good, but
let me know, guys.
Let me know.
What about Phoebe?
Is Phoebe good?
Yeah, am I okay?
Hello.
Yeah, Phoebe sounds good.
Guys, I'm activating my third eye.
I'm gonna be able to answer all the questions now.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you're here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we have anyone with third eyes on here?
Yeah.
I've got a secret third eye.
I have more eyes.
You don't want to know where mine is.
Oh, I know that.
She's made.
Is that allowed?
I'm allowed.
Finds up my butthole.
Yeah.
There you go.
You can see the world with a totally different perspective
down there.
Yeah.
It'll show me the true answers.
I think who's Lady Knott?
She's got a cheat sheet next to her.
Join the game.
Oh yeah, they're ready up.
All right, ready up lady nut.
I'm ready Let's go So glad to see you again.
Barry are you commuted?
You think I'm gonna mute Barry?
They love the game.
No, I'm not.
I'm just I'm just polite So excited.
Mr. Baby
Tiny flower
Lady nut Oh, yeah It's important.
Flash flashy.
Yeah!
Big love.
Yeah, look over here.
Fat finger.
Woohoo!
Captain Loco.
Yeah!
You look better every time I see you.
Please.
Aw.
I think he likes you.
Monty, Ponty, come on.
Yeah, Monty, Ponty.
Jeez, Monty, Ponty.
Oh, you chose!
You chose!
What?
I'm kind of scared.
I'm kind of scared, I'll be honest.
I'm really scared.
Maybe we should have got one that should be the funniest
category, I think.
Mr. Beast.
There has to be a Mr. Beast question.
YouTubers What is the YouTube alias of Felix Kiel?
I know Oh Oh All right, cool For judo Okay Tony M Let's go
What?
I clicked it so quickly We're currently on you to be the
fastest I'm sorry What is the focus of Ryan's world with
Ryan?
Okay, okay, okay, okay Oh, I have no idea Toys!
Toys!
I don't know how to be fast!
I'm 10 years old and I watch Reigns World!
As of 2020, which of these YouTubers has the most fans?
It's gotta be Mr. Beast!
Wait, he's not even on here!
Wait a second!
He's great!
No, still?
As of 2020?
Really?
He doesn't?
2020?
2020!
The context is important!
Huh?
The country's money is still kind of crazy.
He's kind of stalking.
Viral philanthropy?
All right, all right.
Just whatever you say, buddy.
I don't know.
Viral philanthropy would just pop us away.
What is...
What the fuck?
When in doubt we have Minecraft.
Yeah.
Oh, I told you I had to do.
Snap it off.
Yeah, baby.
When in doubt hit Minecraft, this is it.
Hit Minecraft.
Mr. Bied.
Yeah.
You would.
Rink.
I gotta do the twist and twist.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god.
You hit my twisted twist.
Bunky.
Me when I answer all the YouTuber quiz, right?
Bunky, if I may ask.
All those years, you know, training at the swamp on your
phone, you know?
Yeah.
The many, many hours you want to get down in the Everglades.
Oh, no.
Wait.
No, I don't want to mess about your life.
I'm choosing not.
No, I chose the night.
We know this.
It's time for pictures.
Random reveal.
Oh, what's the category again?
Uh, fruits and vegetables.
Okay.
Red fruits and veggies.
Yeah, this is me, guys.
What's cooking here?
Oh, sorry.
Hello?
Oh, I answered it wrong.
Oh, I don't know.
Don't look at me.
Oh.
Dang, I was so close.
Making beats.
I was slow.
It was not very flashy flash.
Win.
Yeah.
You do voice acting for this game?
That sounds like you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I don't know.
Dude, show us the picture.
What is that?
Oh, no.
I chose wrong.
I chose wrong too.
I didn't know, so I clicked the one I didn't know.
Oh, damn it.
Oh, no, it chose right!
I chose right!
What the hell is a rose hip?
Whoa!
Oh, wait, wait!
Why is it got hair?
What fruit is pictured here?
Oh, I know fruit.
Oh, oh!
Oh, no, no!
I love this fruit, but it's so hard to eat.
It is pretty hard to eat, but...
Yeah, it is pretty hard to eat it.
It loves...
Oh, yeah.
Win.
What proof is pictured here?
Oh!
I'm in my element!
I'm finally in my element!
Yes!
Yes, Phoebe!
Do it!
Oh my god, Phoebe!
You're killing it!
Did you get number one answer for...
Or did you get fastest answer for...
Oh, wait, oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh!
I got it.
Okay.
I love raspberries.
Oh, so good.
It's expensive in Japan.
I can get ten for four dollars.
Oh my god.
That's pretty bad.
They're a decoration more than a fruit.
Tiny flower.
Oh my god.
She earned that.
Super time.
We're gonna do howling hips.
Oh.
It's too much for YouTube!
Too much for YouTube!
That's too much!
Oh no, it's not old enough yet.
You're not old enough.
No shirt on?
Monty, if I may, I'll choose no problem.
He's spinning like that.
He did rotate.
Monty, they know the drill.
Rotating.
We know Monty.
We know.
Oh no.
No not.
It's not the Bible priest.
These are all bad.
It's back to the Franco-Belgian comics, yeah.
Oh, I recognize it though, now they saw the picture.
It's Chin-Tin.
Or Tantan.
Tantan in Japan, did you guys know that?
Because they can't say Tintin.
They can't say Tintin for reasons.
So it's Tantan.
Famous characters.
Oh, yeah.
What is the name of May's big neighbor?
Oh!
Fuck, I clicked the wrong thing.
I went for a picture.
I thought it was the picture.
I swear I know it.
I swear.
Mr. Beard, lock in.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm going in.
Hold on.
I'm locked out.
It's always big love.
Alright.
I know.
Oh!
Maybe.
She's gonna do that.
Yeah, see, I got you.
It was a nice moment of...
Well burp.
Nice, nice, nice.
I read that in school and I cried.
Oh, it's me, baby!
Take it back.
Don't do it, don't do it.
Show big love whose balls.
Yes!
Yeah!
Yeah, give me your butt.
Yeah.
Which puppet's nose grows every time he tells a lie.
Oh, easy.
My ping, my ping.
My ping!
How are you so fast?
Who would you like to steam for?
You want to have your finger on the mouse.
Don't do it.
Hold on.
I'm looking okay.
Captain Loco.
Do flash flashy.
Flash flashy.
Flash flashy alone.
The same 300 points.
We're passing it around.
I spit on those.
Lady Nut.
How could you get...
Oh my god!
I put an answer to everything right!
Oof!
You got aimed!
That makes me angry because we are hot head!
Hot everything else too!
Oh my god!
I don't know how you die.
Okie dokie.
I give you fire and you give me okie dokie.
All right.
No, absolutely not US president.
No, get out of it.
Yeah, I don't want US presidents either.
I don't either.
Try to get some big points before the next and final round.
Patient pictures.
All right.
I hate this category.
I'm not very patient.
I only drink water and tea.
Beverages.
Which juice is high in vitamin C?
vitamin c oh wait no that's that's apple oh my god oh you
whiff i saw orange oh sweet i saw the colors apple juice
ain't orange this is rigged rigged was beer originated in
mexico oh i don't know i don't know i don't know huh maybe
what was it that one i don't know it's why did i Maybe they
got yeah, there was like a big controversy during the corona
period.
Yeah, they didn't do too well for a bit Oh, I don't know how
to feel about it's all getting this I didn't know I only I
only I get what everyone I was saying To make cider cider
banana banana definitely lemon You know the the frantic gas
kind of gives it away.
I know I'm sorry Sorry, I just get really excited.
Which drink was created for the University of Florida?
What the?
What?
That's gotta be.
That's it though, isn't it?
Water.
Not water is better.
Huh?
Woo!
Oh, for the Gators!
The Gators!
I can't take you so long to answer.
Well, is we will be submitting.
I don't know.
This is about school.
It's okay.
You were so faster than me.
Somehow school.
And I'm American.
Which photo features a country that does not sell Coca-Cola?
Oh.
Uh oh.
Wait, what?
There's one?
I don't know.
That's the bridge.
I don't freaking know.
I chose the bridge.
Have we already seen it already?
I'll do the train too.
Wait, we didn't see that one!
What the hell?
They never showed us that one!
Oh, they didn't show us that one!
I'm sorry.
Oh.
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
Huge BL moment.
No, I didn't know.
As a dog running from a crazy cat.
Yes, Minto.
Look at the dance.
I'm doing the running rave.
He's gonna run out of here.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Whoa.
Did you train to do that?
That's crazy.
Look at that dog in her.
Look at that weenie go.
She got that dog in her.
ever.
It's time for the last round.
Okay, here we go.
God, I love when they get the only one that matters.
Oh, boy.
The more points you score, the more time you get.
Answer as quickly as you can.
Last player remaining is the winner.
Alright, where we are?
Ooh.
Wow.
He's solid.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we're all kind of like the same.
We locked in this time.
Big load.
this time yeah we're used to it now yeah yeah yeah my little
pony my little pony oh oh what is not a my little pony you
hate me you hate me i don't know oh i messed up i whiffed i
i was wrong oh they don't wait no wait i was right oh yeah
sorry my background was red so i thought that okay okay
Inventions?
Inventions.
Cahooded.
When was the first ballpoint pen inventions?
What?
Uh...
Who knows?
Do you ever see those ASMR videos where they like run the
ballpointed pen over like the and you like watch the ball
roll?
Yeah.
And it's like so close.
I think Barry is.
I guess.
I just get lucky.
Indiana Jones.
What is Indiana Jones's superpower?
Oh, he's just a guy.
He's just a guy.
He's a guy.
Wait,
none was an option.
Oh, no.
What the hell?
I didn't realize that none was an option.
I just cling something.
That's valid.
Oh, actually, I don't know.
Me, I'm like 10%.
Oh, oh.
That's really...
Darn it, stupid!
I might be dead.
Goodbye!
Get back there!
Get back there, guys!
What is back to the buster?
Oh!
Okay.
What?
All the questions I know after I die.
Deloian.
mythical mythology how many labors are attributed to
hercules labors i don't know who's that labors i don't know
definitely 12.
what the labor i chose 12 to seven oh damn it you guys don't
know your labors why don't you who's the jobless bummer now
friends like literally or her now character's nickname oh
what what julia roberts julia roberts huh who's julia It's
probably like string bean.
That makes sense.
Oh my god, it's underpants!
Oh my god, she saved.
Yes, Minto.
Oh my god.
Animals.
Why does the mole build tunnels?
Oh.
Dark.
Uh.
I don't know why does anyone build a tunnel.
No, dang it.
I think they could also look for water.
What the hell?
Sayonara!
Wait, what?
You guys got it!
Oh my god!
Phoebe, we're counting on you!
We gotta beat the tiny part.
Phoebe, sorry you!
We gotta lock in.
Famous movie directors.
Please be one that I know.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna kill me for this.
Oh, who is this?
Guardians of the Galaxy.
I don't know.
No, I'm dead.
I'm done for it.
Oh no.
Wait, really?
Goodbye guys.
Oh no.
Oh no, I'm still in it.
I'm still in it.
She does action moves.
Go to the Fed.
I have to.
I have no time.
Oh my god.
Go on.
Lady Nugue.
The U .S.
Presidents were an only child.
What?
Two of them.
No!
Zero!
What does that mean?
You can't really.
You can't really be an only child.
Yeah.
Lady Nugue!
Lady Nugue.
Jennifer, Jennifer.
Not, not, not, not, not, not, not, not, not.
Lady Nut.
I ain't cheering that.
Yeah, yeah, I'm saying that.
I'm gonna do it with the shaky shake.
The shake and shake.
I was very close.
I should have known.
Oh my gosh, shake those boobies.
Oh my gosh.
We're like shaking them in tiny flowers.
Traumatized.
You're shaking them in your face.
Wow.
It was fun.
Everybody get up and celebrate with some funky moves.
Congrats, Beastie.
That's one point.
You can go to buffers.tv on your phone and enter the phone.
Wait, it reset.
Oh, it reset.
Why did it reset?
Oh, no.
Oh, what reset?
My character.
Mine did too.
Oh, I don't see your characters.
Yeah, we're not in yet.
Because what the hell?
Front row.
That seems weird.
Well, sorry.
Both Mint and Phoebe.
Beasties, what are you up to?
This seems like some sabotage.
Yeah.
I click my kick Densetsu button.
Densetsu button.
I feel like I need to change my name to something a little
more.
Like, is it menacing?
Yeah, you gotta evolve and power up.
I don't even see you guys in here.
I don't know why.
I made my character.
What does it mean?
Oh yeah, wait, we're not in anymore.
Yeah, we're not in.
What?
There you go.
Crazy cow.
Someone joined.
Wait, who's that?
That one is me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Why haven't I joined that?
I had to like go back and refresh and do it again.
Yeah.
Maybe refresh.
Ah, that makes sense.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
That's kind of mean.
That's fine.
That's true.
That's you now.
I think I'm gonna be Uncle Flower now.
Oh, good job.
Uncle Flower.
I don't know like that.
Uncle Flower is a bib.
Just a reminder of who the names are, I am Lady Nutt.
I'm Mr. Beard.
I'm such a fork.
Hell yeah.
I'm big love.
Down with big love.
I'm big hate.
Also, I've got to pee.
Can I be right back?
Yes, girl.
I thought I could hold it this time.
I'm sorry.
You're good.
Don't worry.
You know what?
Actually, this is a great time for a slime drape.
Everybody should hide it.
Everybody hide it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I was going to say good.
Here's a...
I was going to say good time for some trash talk, but...
Oh, yeah, yeah, trash talk.
Well, here's some fun facts.
Now that I'm hydrated, uh, Dead Sets are Stinks, boom.
Oh, my God.
Did you actually know that... Wait, who is that?
Who's Lord Dude?
Who is that?
Is that Stainer?
Did someone join on their PC and their Wait, who is that?
Who is that?
We should just let them join.
I think this is just a random.
They could be the fourth Densetsu member.
There is no chat.
Wait, the code's not even public.
Yeah, how do they join?
I don't know.
Lord Dude.
Why is Lord Dude looking at us?
Wait, they're controlling.
Lord Fingers.
That's their manager.
He's come to pat out the rings.
But how did Starter know the code?
Yeah, he doesn't know the code.
I don't know.
I think someone joined twice.
Oh.
Oh, maybe.
Wait.
But they're like changing things.
They're changing their name.
What if it's, what if it's Phoebe on the toilet?
Well, oh, maybe.
Well, either way, we can't start unless they click done.
Oh, right.
Oh.
okay well i guess we'll find out once phoebe comes back
maybe yeah also did you guys just a fun fact for the
audience i don't like lord finger being in our game they're
all rooting for lord finger does lord finger get their own
points if they win no that's that's a gen 2 guys that's
that's a gen 2 oh my god the leak what color is Lord Finger.
Lord Finger is ready.
Oh my God.
Mom, now, what is that?
We've all been replaced by Lord Finger, everybody.
Phoebe, are you Lord Finger?
Please tell us now.
I am not Lord Finger.
I'm something flower.
How did Lord Finger get in here?
Who is it?
Tiny Flower.
I think I will still be.
Chat really likes Lord Finger though, so.
they're gonna know all the answers i just know it getting
their own points or are they joining team i think they're
they're joining that joining that joining that's oh my god
lord finger's about to walk in cheating how is it cheating
you have four members i mean i know it i mean technically i
could kick lord finger do you want me to no wait let's do a
game with him let's do it we can do one more round my ocee
one of the ocee marks he's just sitting on the couch mr
beard mr beard yeah people are putting the lord finger ocee
marks in the chat
that's crazy
The theme of 2026 is just saying that everyone's joining
Dentsetsu.
Lord Finger.
Who are you?
Who is that?
If they're using AIMBOT though, I'm going to ask.
That's what I'm feeling.
You're like capable.
things that we are not yeah they gotta plop us quiz aimbot
tick tock tick tock i don't think i know anything about no
no tick tock i don't know i don't know how it's junior why
is tick tock it's so it's so demotivating when it's his
junior i know my special interests what do you mean mont
gomery stop it it's so over it's so jill beasties.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
Roxanne, Roxanne.
What?
I don't know.
Okay.
Why is this TikTok?
This is just a song.
It's just a song.
Yeah, what is this?
Oh.
What?
What is this?
Oh, she wanted to party all night.
Okay, sorry guys.
That's what I thought too.
Oh, that's what I thought too.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I saw ghost and I locked in.
You gotta represent.
Respectable.
Nice, nice.
The way Lord Fanger is actually playing.
Oh god.
Wait, who is this?
Oh no, I saw the wrong one.
I clicked the wrong one because of the license.
Wait, who is it?
I don't know who these people are, but I got them.
Yes!
So you're telling me a kid would know the answers to this
better than we.
I think a kid would.
I think so.
Oh, wait, what happens on TikTok when Black?
What happens?
What's the song?
I don't know.
I don't know I should have known Barry.
I should have known.
It wouldn't make sense.
Am I the only one who got it?
Am I older?
Can they have a slogan?
I don't know.
What?
Dude, I don't even like put one in.
Second counts vine?
Oh, okay.
Like every second.
That makes sense, though.
That one makes sense, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah.
Awesome nest!
This is my new vocal stance.
I know.
Flashy, you've got the most points.
Yeah, of course you did.
You got a lot of points.
Warfinger, what the hell?
I got you with a jazzy jump.
Whoa.
Oh, fancy.
She's riding a unicycle.
Oh my god.
I'm a mime in another life.
Oh, that's beautiful.
That music is so old.
Epic dance.
Tap the buttons to move the arrow.
Tap, tap, tap to choose a category.
All right.
I'm ready to fight.
Okie dokie.
What we got.
Do you know New Zealand?
No, we do not know New Zealand.
We might know.
question that's not a category you've never heard of it the
question is just yes or no and then they move on to the next
round random reveal press a button when you know what the
picture is okay quickly okay okay this is gonna make me
crave fruits man I know that's how I'm feeling I don't want
to pick it I'm like I'm home which citrus fruit is this oh
okay oh easiest question in my life that was really hard
oops please don't say Wait, I think it's a clementine.
It's a mandarin.
It's a tiny.
What's the difference?
I never know.
Manderins are tiny.
They're so good.
Aren't clementines tiny?
I thought they were like more yellow.
What's a stone?
What is a stone fruit?
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
That makes sense.
A fruit with a stoning.
How does it make sense?
It's not a stone.
It comes from a stone.
Which fruit has rocks in it?
Yeah, what does that mean?
Yeah, what's a stone?
Don't mangoes grow on trees?
Wait, I don't want to answer that.
If that's stupid, don't answer.
Wait, what?
What is it?
I'm just going to start putting stuff.
What is that?
I'm just asking, but I don't...
It's an apple.
Oh, God!
Oh!
What the heck?
I was assuming it was from somewhere like, I don't know,
European.
It was blended by Johnny Appleseed.
Yeah!
Yeah, right?
Wait, there's too many, there's too much variation in these.
There's either 12 or 60,000.
That seems like a lot.
What the...
Uh...
Of just the payer?
3,000!
What?
That's a lot of proof.
I know my pair trivia.
It's almost more likely so does Lord Finger.
Let's go Lord Finger.
He's kind of doing bad, I'll be honest.
Lord Finger, pick up the pace, dude.
Dude, you're letting the people down.
You have less than him, please.
Hey, hey!
Hey!
Yeah, dude.
Stop coming after our teammate, isn't it?
Yeah!
Mr. Beard, you got the most points.
Mr. Beard!
Mr. Beard feels like dancing.
That's a lot of varieties of mirrors.
Why is Skip Dance in Red?
For a lot of, for like, a mid-tier fruit.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's like a skipping...
I thought it was like a graphic.
A new category?
the buttons to move the arrow you get ejected if you skip
tap tap tap tap we know ah
I literally stood up I literally stood up I was frantically
pressing
things that was crazy things that make you say you what is
not found in snot what the hell
big love who would you like to steal points from how is it
always big love this is crazy yeah i love
Warfinger!
Are we all gonna bully him?
They're on your team, so they're just giving you extra
points.
What is not easily found in dust?
What are these questions?
Popcorn kernels could be dust.
Is popcorn dust?
Uh oh.
Who would you like to steal points from?
I don't know.
I think, uh...
What the hell?
I just took from the first person.
I saw.
We were like nine people.
Three sections.
Uh-oh.
Which is not one of those parts.
B.L.
Lock in.
Uh.
Oh, it's easy.
What?
Oh, I think I got it wrong.
Oh, no.
Wait, what?
Why do you guys always click that?
Oops.
Mr. B.
Uh, sorry.
Did you...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Loring.
She's throwing.
Oh, no.
Loring finger.
Hi guys!
Guys, I'm out of it.
My dad walked into the room.
My controller stopped working.
No, no, no, no.
What's Lord Finger gonna do?
What's Lord Finger doing?
Lord Finger, we will avenge you.
We will avenge you, Lord Finger.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, he's angry.
He's angry.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Lord Finger can get down.
Monty, you could learn some moves from that.
Monty.
Monty is the robot.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Monty, stop it.
They know how to tap.
Why is he so muted?
Um, aquatic animals!
Aquatic!
Yeah!
My little pony.
Yeah, I was trying to.
I don't know how to choose.
Try to get some big points before the next and final round.
The Oshimark spam with the chest.
I know.
It is so funny.
Crown finger up.
Aquatic animals.
Okay.
Which animal lacks a brain and heart?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, we know.
Wait!
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I messed up.
Oh, I thought it was okay.
Uh oh.
Areas using shambles.
Nice.
Dude, I'm washed.
Wait, Lord Finger, what the hell, man?
That's the most dangerous feature.
Characterized by male pregnancy.
Oh!
Oh my god, lock in!
Lock in!
I almost clicked.
Don't misclick.
Where are you at?
Show him to me.
Yes!
We got really excited about M-Preg.
M-Preg.
M-Preg in Popper's quiz?
I'm really excited.
Amazing.
Lord Finger knows everything.
Everyone got it.
There's a girlfriend.
Nicknamed Seekam.
Oh, I fat fingered it.
I fat fingered it.
Oh, oops.
I love a manatee.
It looks like rocks.
I love them.
Oh, stupid.
Stupid.
I would love to have been the person who got to record that.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
Was it that one?
He just looks right.
Don't know.
Wait,
we got that right?
No, we didn't.
Oh my god, step away.
Oh no.
How the hell?
What is this?
Yeah!
Jellyfish.
Alright.
They are so big brain.
It took me a while to remember what an invertebrate was.
Me too.
I'm literally in your remembers.
Alright.
Blocked in.
Flash flashy.
Cat dance Don't matter if I do Get you with a little Rodeo
Rumble Have we seen this one?
This is going down style Oh Sexy lady Okay Sexy lady You
could learn some moves from that It's a time for the last
round Final fight Alright here we go Yeah let's go right
They picked all the hard like questions for this one they do
as quickly as the other one's like it's a cat we don't get
the pick yeah exactly lord finger we're counting on you we
believe in you you can do this lord finger carry lord finger
carry oh lord finger carry wasn't flashy love nope but we'll
get it we'll get it in the crazy mark that's so crazy i'll
lock in i'll lock in everyone lock Okay.
Okay.
Which of these films does not star Arnold Schwarzenegger?
Ardo, no.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Is he in Robocop?
I think I know.
Oh, okay.
He wasn't in Robocop.
Oh, that was Terminator.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Extreme sports.
Uh-oh.
What?
Okay.
Which sport involves jumping from fixed objects with a
parachute?
Oh.
from fixed what oh no is it probably cliff parachuting wait
wait no wait how do you jump in any of them without a
parachute yeah yes lord finger go lord finger oh my god lord
finger lord finger are you british populist state oh my god
i don't know oh sorry wait a second Oh, fuck.
I read it.
I got it!
I should have known it!
Wait, Lord Finger is going crazy!
Yes, go Lord Finger!
Oh my god.
I'm going.
Oh.
What was the cover name for D-Day?
Oh, shh.
Uh, brr.
Wait, isn't it Omaha?
Oh, no.
Oh, shh.
Yeah!
It's over.
Mr. Beer's over.
Mr. Beer's over too.
It's over.
Come on, Minto and Lord Finger, you can do it.
You can do it!
Which event awards the Borgwana trophy.
What is that?
What the fuck?
I don't know.
I just picked that.
Oh, damn.
Oh, no!
Lord Finger is fucking cheating.
Yes, Lord Finger!
Oh, my God!
Lord Finger!
No way, yeah.
Yeah!
Where was the first recipe for potato chips?
There's no way he sandbagged this entire time.
Oh!
Oh, I know this one.
I know this one.
I don't know this one.
Oh, shit.
We got this lady nut.
Oh, wait, I got it!
I got it!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, we're cooked.
We're cooked.
Oh, no.
The next one.
Legend of Zelda.
Oh, wait.
Come on.
You got this one.
Which is a recurring legendary weapon in the Zelda series.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, you know this one.
The buster sword!
Everyone's got that.
Kings and queens.
Okay, Mickey whispered to me right here.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I have no idea.
Not a clue.
Wait, is it kings?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Oh, good lord Bengals!
Big love!
Big love, it's just you, Liv!
Oh my god!
Oh, unless I know my fruits!
Approximately how many different potatoes?
Oh my god, why would you invite two of us?
Guess hi, guess hi, 400...
Oh, it's...
No, John can't be that way!
No, I gotta...
I gotta run.
Yes!
Are you guys?
20,000 fruits, but there's 4,000 potatoes?
Oh...
Yes.
I'm in danger.
Oh no.
Oh no!
What is a Padawan?
Oh!
It's the little creature guy, right?
No, it's a big one!
What?
Just give me a...
This is so close!
Recovery!
Olympics!
Oh this is so messed up.
Oh god, oh god.
Seven?
Why?
I don't know.
I think it's Melbourne.
Damn it!
Is it quite?
I tried that word!
No way Lord Finger fucking clutched this up.
I'm fucking kicking Lord Finger out.
Yes!
Hey, I'm still here too!
I would still be here!
Zigg at the Sharko?
Zigg?
Probably Zigg, right?
We're like completely ignoring- What is this?
Stop!
Okay, Lord Finger.
How?
Look at him!
Oh!
Oh no!
It's so over.
Buddy, enjoy your last dance.
You are the winner.
You are the final supper.
This is your final dance, bud.
Pick a big one.
Good one.
Banana bounce out?
Yes.
Who are you?
Welcome.
This guy.
We're never gonna know.
He only hot hand dances.
Dude, how do you sandbags so hard on the...
MVPF!
everybody get up and celebrate with some funky I'm not
dancing I'm abstaining don't be jealous don't be jealous on
your phone and enter the code does he join he can't get back
in
that means it's one point densetsu one point beastie so this
decides everything team smarts cider oh my god even like
beat us all and then hey i have my own i feel like i deserve
the prophecy
the prophecy see you again papa's quest yeah they densest it
would have won anyway because of exactly yeah he really the
three hearts and then the fingering mode
What was that guy?
What the heck?
What happened to you?
Oh my, my cheeks hurt.
Dang it.
Sir Falk.
You're so tired.
I know, they're just kind of like, what do they do with you?
Oh my god, they just don't care.
What's happening?
I'm just stretching.
Big love.
You look better every time I see you.
Oh, please.
Please.
Oh, you.
Trap the buttons to move the arrow.
Monty Ponte.
Come on.
They know this stuff.
I love you, Monty Ponte.
Right now!
Don't let it!
No!
I don't know anything about strategy.
Let's start with the first of five rows.
I'm not confident in this at all.
Yo, I don't know anything.
Demagorgon!
That's the first answer.
Stranger things?
Let's go.
Oh!
Oh, I know this one.
Yeah, this is a, this is like a really old game, so...
It's gonna be like a review one.
Oh, okay, okay.
That's true.
He's fine.
Demogorgon.
Demogon.
How does Lucas protect his girlfriend, Max?
Oh, this is not season one.
Wait, what?
Oh, season two.
Um, oh, I don't know.
Huh?
I chose wrist rocket, but that doesn't really make much
sense.
I chose thrush ice cream.
Go-go gadget.
Wrist rocket.
What?
That's it!
What does that mean?
What?
They wrote that in?
What is your nickname?
He gets a new nickname?
This is like Conan levels of...
Wait, Debra!
Debra!
Hey guys, this is so messed up.
I don't know anything about this.
Debra would want an exchange for crawling through air ducts
that lead to a storage room.
Who's Erica?
Uh...
Oh, it probably is like Lucas's.
Is that the sister?
Oh, yeah, it's the sister.
Lucas's sister.
Damn, I want free ice cream for life.
Yeah, me too.
She'd want her brother's allowance.
Who created Stranger Things?
Oh, I do know this.
Yeah, I know this one too.
No, wait.
Everyone's mad at them right now.
Oh, fuck.
The Wachowski siblings?
It's like the first thing that said siblings, because I know
they weren't.
The sibling siblings.
The siblings.
Crazy Doc, you got the most fun.
Yay!
I don't know anything about Stranger Things.
You did great.
yeah where you going she's prepping she's prepping this is
how you're gonna be this is gonna be her auntie you could
learn some moves from that can you stop being mean to Monty
my guy we love Monty in this house you're making it really
awkward for everybody here yeah what have we got No!
What are we doing?
Sports equipment!
It's got to be fair game for everyone.
Yeah, we're technically all monsters.
It's time for pictures.
Here we go.
Okay, here we go.
Press a button when you know what the picture is.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, this is literally beasts.
Oh, God.
Crap.
Pressure.
I'm not even gonna make a joke, man.
I'm gonna be dead silent
Huh a finger huh?
I don't like this picture what the fuck?
What is it?
What the hell is that?
What is that?
Lord finger reveal?
I think it's Jack the Giant Killer.
Oh, okay.
What?
Oh, okay That's not a mythical dream.
Yeah.
On this vase.
Someone already guessed.
Yeah, I'm just guessing.
I'm just guessing.
Yeah.
Oh, no, I shouldn't have guessed.
I shouldn't have guessed.
We can't.
We can't just go...
I'm...
I'm growing.
Are we gonna do a baby?
Chin Chin is out.
Defeated?
Defeated.
I'm gonna...
Dude, I don't know the statue.
Oh, I think I know it actually.
Maybe.
I'm guessing.
I just guessed.
Oh my fucking god!
Stop!
It's the milking farm.
I don't know.
I don't want to see this.
There's a lot of sausages out, aren't there?
There's so many...
This is a sausage party.
There's so many paintings in the mythical...
It's a beef sausage, man.
Name it is dog.
I'm just guessing.
Yeah, just guessing.
I guess the only dog I knew.
Yeah, I got it right.
Thank you, Hades.
I am in my element!
Woo!
Oh, yeah.
I'm not knowing any stranger things, trivia.
Which monster is this?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yes?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That was my bad.
Oops.
I bad fingered it.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that stranger thinks category was rough for me.
Mr. B.
S.
He's gombed for us.
What does that mean?
Cowling show.
Mr. Beer, can you do this?
Cowling showdown.
Of course.
Oh my god.
Mr. Beer.
Mr. Beer, this is appropriation.
Mr. Beer to just make it up and go inside me out.
I know karate.
I'll show you.
Watch this.
It was like watching a nine-year-old do it.
It was like snowing into it with like a broomstick.
My friend and I made this dance.
Roblox!
No!
Not literature!
I hate books!
Okay, 90s music then.
Now, you don't make it to me.
Finally, we get to steal points again.
That was the biggest fight yet, I think.
Don't let Barry win.
Don't let her have the satisfaction.
Please!
Steal points from the player with the most points.
All right, whatever.
Just lock in, I guess.
Nineteenth music.
I guess.
Which country music star sings about friends in low places?
Oh, my God, friends in low places.
Who are these people?
I don't know what it is, though.
I know the song.
Tale McGraw.
Oh, shit.
Oh, dang, I thought it was.
I didn't know.
Nobody knew that.
It didn't even sound like a country name.
I don't know what that is.
I'm sorry for you.
How did we choose this again?
Oh, I have no idea.
I don't know.
I'm gonna guess.
Mr. Beard, who would you like to steal voice from?
Mr. Beard.
Flashy, Flashy.
Crazy, crazy.
Oh no, I can't read when everyone's talking.
No!
Okay, fair enough.
That works, that works, that works, that works.
Which song by Madonna encouraged listeners to strike a pose?
Strike a pose.
Oh.
This is- I'm feeling everyone knew that.
Oh, wait, I should have read.
I did not know with my bad.
Of course it's- I did not.
Whoa.
Yeah, it's me!
Okay, uh...
Don't do it.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Crazy dork.
Wow.
Woohoo.
Lady Nut.
Evil.
How could you get so few points?
Ouch.
What the hell?
What happened to you twice?
Why did he call you out like that?
You know what?
I'm gonna skip the dance because you heard my feelings,
dude.
Lady Nut.
Oh, no.
Wow.
She's pissed.
Vibe killer.
Don't be a sore loser.
They know tap, tap, tap.
All right, what we got here.
Absolutely not US President.
Food around the world.
Oh yeah.
I don't think the Americans.
What are you going to think I would not know?
I see how many they asked us how many of them were only
children.
How would I know...
Yeah, what the heck?
What the heck?
I think that's a common trivia question, though.
The food pictures are making me hungry, though.
Yeah, I know.
Me too.
Went back at it.
Which sandwich are you likely to find in Greece?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Yeah?
I only knew from the gas.
You need to mute my mic.
I get excited about the right answer.
Just the popping sound was crazy.
This photo shows a popular way to eat fish in Portugal.
To eat fish.
Uh.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Flashy flash.
We are the same.
Nice, nice.
Oh.
Pia, you gotta lock in.
I'm so serious.
Please be us.
She's gonna leave us.
Oh, I'm...
Oh, I don't know, man.
I don't know.
Mmm, I love a good girl.
Oh, wait, no.
I miss red.
Oh, I thought it was a different thing than this.
I thought those were...
Are those not lentils?
I thought it was spinach.
No.
Someone's got to pick.
It's Lady Nut.
Lady Nut.
Oh, I was right!
They never showed it, like, two times.
Delicious.
They showed coffee four times.
Mmm.
Lentil.
Delicious.
Like our delicious victory.
Oh.
Wait, was that it?
Everyone picked it.
Wait, wait.
It was to, and that was to Jean, I think.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
We had to wait for the cycle back.
We had no shame, Vicky.
It's such a shame.
I do realize we are not finished sauce.
Mmm, I want to eat all of these.
Which meat is famously produced in Spain and Portugal.
You guys make me freak out.
Everybody starts cooking.
I think I'm showing you the first one.
I guess they didn't say which meat and then they showed
meat.
Yeah, you bericho ham.
The bericho ham is really popular in Japan, but I don't
think that they...
Oh, really?
I think it's actually just like lunch meat.
They give out and say it's a miracle ham.
Oh, yeah.
Why would they do that?
I finally get a dog.
Let's go.
What dance will you do?
Which one?
I don't think we've had the zombie zone halfway.
She's forking dancing.
Oh,
this is a Michael Jackson, right?
Yeah, this is just Michael Jackson.
Oh, my God.
Because this is thriller.
What a dance.
It's time for the last.
round all right okay this is where it all matters here we go
here we go i'll bring it back i'll bring it back i promise
bring it back as you can last player remaining is the winner
i'd be shocked if pio like won this to be honest that'd be
like the craziest comeback story you gotta believe not in
like a mean way but like kind of wow i think you really are
trying to no i love beasties i Big love, big love, big love.
Big love.
Oh, catch me.
Who uses the comeback?
I know you are.
But what am I?
Someone uses that?
Someone actually does that?
I don't know.
I picked one!
Oh, shit, really?
I guess.
This is crack.
Why does that just like it?
I know.
Pee-wee Herman, I know.
Whoa!
Oh shoot, I don't know geography.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
All right.
I don't know.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Get out!
Get out of there, dude.
Rigged.
No, no, no.
Go Lady Knight, go!
I've always believed in you.
Signphone.
Signphone!
I don't know signphone.
Who inspired the character Kramer.
Oh, oh!
Who is Kramer?
Oh, wait.
I think I picked the wrong.
No, I bet the other neighbor.
I bet the other neighbor.
I don't know.
I leave those.
I've been getting all of the wrong.
The fall of Mr. Beard.
Of the following, which is considered a normal blood
pressure.
What the fuck?
Oh, I think I just clicked one that I just clicked the one
that gave me blood.
Oh, yeah.
You did.
Yeah.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm flopping here.
No, no, we can do it.
We can do it.
Then set to...
Australian TV.
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
On the street, do the neighbors characters live.
Oh, oh, oh.
Neighbors.
Thank you.
Thank you, Vicky Mama, for making me watch all our
neighbors.
Shit, this is it for me, guys.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Mr. Beard is out.
Mr. Beard lives.
No, he doesn't.
I'm glad Mr. Beard got shaved.
Who will do viral for lab now?
What is the most expensive restaurant in the world?
Who knows?
That has a fancy name.
Mezzler?
No.
Okay.
Stop that emotion.
Dude, I'm him.
I'm my champion.
Flashy Flash.
Flashy Flash goes to the top restaurant.
Flashy Flash goes to this flashy restaurant.
What can I say?
I can't get to all the flashing flashy flesh does.
What?
You get paid.
I'm not the same without Lord thinking.
I'm just I'm just I'm craving him.
There's shambles.
I know this because of the meme.
I only know it because of the meme with the map.
I don't know.
I think the only reason I know that it is.
Wait, I know.
Oh, God!
Yo, I want the best use.
Oh, no.
These animals live in female dominated groups.
Oh, um, fuck.
I don't know.
No, I don't know.
I got it wrong.
Oh, yeah.
Keep living.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I love.
U .S.
history.
No.
Oh, no.
What has celebrated the 4th of July?
Oh, come on.
Oh, you know this one.
You know this one.
I think.
I don't know.
You got this one.
Yeah.
You got your people.
Okay.
You got it.
Of course.
She knows that one.
It was crazy.
Brings.
RIGED!
I don't know!
Oh my god, this is so rigged.
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, big love, big love.
Yes, come on.
What was the name of the historical Islamic Empire based
around modern day Turkey?
This one's so easy.
Oh, that one's easy, yeah.
Easy?
Yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
You watched as much Hitalia as I did.
Okay.
Who is Jupiter's father?
Oh, you got this, you got this, you got this.
Oh.
Oh, holy big love, there's nothing we don't know.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I can't believe it's still going on.
Free!
Oh my gosh!
Who knows?
I don't know.
Rigged!
You have to pick something.
Big love win for us!
Who's that?
Big love!
You know what?
And also, I dedicate this win to my group.
Which is your...
Alright, buddy.
Come on.
My group.
You know, the real one The real ones no.
I think we vote Berrybug out.
The real ones no.
BL always wins.
We're going to Ikebukuro!
This was fun.
Everybody get up and celebrate with some funky moves.
Shout out to my groupies.
I think we're all team smarts and just Barry can be team
smart.
I think so too.
Yeah.
We're all winners.
No.
I think there do have.
There has to be a loser.
There has to be a loser for there to be winners.
You know what I mean?
Bear, yeah.
It's a metaphor for life.
I won the game.
May I just comment on the percentage of American questions
in that final round.
It started so British that I thought this game was British
because it was like, you know, like the Ireland and
whatever.
Then they slowly phased those out.
Absolutely ridiculous.
It was karma for the Stranger Things category.
Yeah, probably.
Fair enough.
So...
Does this mean...
Does this mean that these things are winnings?
Team Chair?
Who is the winner?
I mean, I guess you guys shouldn't have disavowed me so
early in the stream.
I don't know.
Maybe...
Maybe if you guys didn't like...
We told you you could be back on the team if you brought on
home.
We love bugs.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's so hard.
I'm calling couples counseling again.
I can't believe this is the third time this tweet.
She's gonna get, she's gonna hate us.
Every pink and green and blue and red.
Oh, my God.
Who the hell was that?
What would it be like flesh here?
Oh no.
Densetsu.
Densu.
They're running off and making a gen together in a whole...
It's not even Densetsu or Beasties.
It's just a whole new unit.
It's just Barry and Lord Fingers.
Yeah.
Getting contact with that guy afterwards.
Alright, anyways, in all serious news, congrats to both of
us for winning.
We all won today.
Yeah!
Very lost.
No, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
That's actually factually untrue.
Statistically correct.
Someone in the chat, someone in the chat got really
mathematical about it and said, team chair has 1.33.
Team Densets AXE has 1.33, and BC's have 1.33, which means a
chair loses.
So, um...
Yay, Team Densets have BC!
I guess it isn't funny anymore.
We don't want to be a loser.
They pulled out the calculators to see what happens.
According to my calculation.
I'm tricky.
But yeah, thanks guys for coming to the collab.
It was really fun.
It was so fun.
It was a lot of fun.
I love Beasties and Densetsu.
Aww.
I love Beasties and Densetsu too.
And also, in seriousness, I am a member of Beasties.
For anyone who is uninitiated, I am a member of Beasties.
For now.
Team meeting after this.
Wait, she doesn't mean that she's leaving.
It means that she's getting kicked out.
She just doesn't want to be on team five.
We know the truth.
I just want to be a winner.
I just want to be a winner, guys.
Come on.
Yeah.
It was really fun.
We should play again.
Yeah, that was actually a lot more fun than I thought.
Yeah.
Pickle Quiz is coming out this year.
Pickle Quiz.
Is that real?
Yeah, that sounds like something Pia Mega.
I know, right?
Is that real?
My psychosis?
No, it's real.
It's real.
Yeah.
You should try it.
Google it.
Pickle Quiz.
pickle quiz you know what i always wanted to play but it's
not very good it's the um are you smarter than a fifth
grader but i heard that a lot of the questions are wrong no
you can't really play it but in theory it would be pretty
funny collab yeah i'm down i'm down for anything yeah i had
a great time stuff too because that yeah yeah we got perfect
numbers for that that was all fun Yeah, thanks for being
here.
Yeah, thank you guys.
That they want to plug, give an outro or anything.
We start with Den Satsu.
Oh.
Mint your thing.
Mint, yeah.
Mint, yeah, your hint.
My thing.
I'm doing a 3D jazz live show.
February 13th.
Tickets are sold out for the venue, but there will be
streaming tickets.
Woo!
Yay!
So definitely keep an eye out for that.
Also, uh, Densetsu.exe's fan club is opening up very, very,
very, very, very, very soon!
Woo!
It's gonna be super exciting, so keep an eye out for that.
Is that like the...
What can we expect from the fan club?
Yeah, it's gonna be our monthly Patreon.
It's gonna be like, uh, stuff that's exclusive to each
month.
It's the best way to directly support the group.
So, hope to see people there.
Fun time.
Yeah, you will see Vicky's 500-word paragraph on why she
likes Stranger Things.
And she's already been written 6,000 times.
You know what else?
You know what else we've got coming.
Lord Fingers, Deb, you straight now.
Lord Fingers!
Lord Fingers.
Sorry I didn't work out for you very well.
We can take you back.
He's the one.
I guess.
It's over, man.
But you do have to clean.
You do have to clean the Beasties Hall for like the next
month.
Do I have to be in like the basement too?
Can I be, can I have an actual room or am I, am I kicked
out?
We'll, we'll discuss it.
You gotta stay in the basement but we'll feed you sometimes
at least.
Oh man.
You can keep your chair.
How much room do you need?
You can keep the chair.
Oh my god.
Am I wrong?
That's rude to say.
But also, she's right.
Can't I stay on, like, one of your shoulders?
I mean, that would be pretty cute, but I'm still mad at you,
so...
Damn.
Okay, well, I guess we're having a group meeting after this.
The next stream will be the future of Beasties.
Oh, no.
Dot, dot, dot, dot.
black thumbnail no we're all gonna be sitting on a couch and
we're gonna be really serious we're gonna be like guys we're
all on the couch and you're on like a single chair in the
corner time out corner it's over did we have anything we
want to we want to announce beastie side do we got merch
check out we do have merch yeah we got it's a limited
edition check it out limited merch that's for like another
two weeks or so yeah and also we have uh a thing at a la
anime los angeles yeah that's right that's right we're gonna
be in the concert at a la and there might be a surprise
guest so uh if you happen to be in california and you got
some time to spare come say hi to us we're also doing
meeting there yeah yeah i think that's cool i think that's
it yeah i think that's it wait also wait also i just want to
i just want to celebrate dory congrats on 50k and happy
birthday Yay!
Yay!
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
My little baby is grown up.
I love my cotton candy wife.
Great.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
But thanks for coming to the MVP TCP stream.
F stream.
It rolls right off the tongue.
Yeah.
Yeah, baby.
Well, until next time, I guess.
Bye-bye.
Thank you, everybody.
Muted.
Oh, I'm still speaking.
Muted apart from me.
Sorry, guys.
Bye.